[La musique]
Berlin était très dévastée et moi
tombe maintenant que nous sommes ici comme ça
faire une promenade des photos de l'époque
1945 ce que je n'ai pas vécu à ça
ici les soldats se tenaient et dem
Les Berlinois ont chanté avec
perdre la chanson bien connue
[La musique]
Mais c'est comme ça aujourd'hui, je pense que c'est normal
ces gens vont d'est en ouest
et beaucoup ne savent même pas que dans
Berlin
est marqué où le mur
était et ici vous avez aussi la ligne
où se trouvait le mur si vous exactement
regardez c'est à seulement cinq mètres du
Bâtiment du Reichstag
oui et la seule histoire que j'ai
peut dire la chaleur aux petits enfants
les demandes des américains ils m'ont dit
pourquoi avez-vous le bâtiment du reichstag dessus
le mur construit oui c'est comme ça quand tu
l'histoire n'existe pas
quelle ligne et aussi des châtaignes
1991 j'avais postulé j'étais en
dans cette maison pour la première fois
c'était gros c'était effrayant j'ai
pensé ou a besoin de plus de temps
vous savez tout sur ce bâtiment
c'est allé plus vite que je ne le pensais
et à presque 25 ans j'entends alors aux alentours
J'ai fait l'expérience de la conversion
après la chute du mur par l'année
Norman Foster britannique
qui a été totalement vidé seulement ceux
façade se tenait les murs extérieurs et l'homme
puis construit un nouveau
la maison ne pouvait rien faire pour lui
Socialisme national
il avait été construit avant et c'était
simplement détourné à des fins qui
Les Allemands ne sont pas recherchés
oui pourquoi est-ce que je dis que c'est mon immeuble
que c'est un professionnel dans lequel vous évoluez
quelque chose qui grandit en devient un
chose et j'ai beaucoup de gens
dit des choses et ce n'était pas facile
dit quelque chose mais j'ai le
les gens ont regardé j'ai des petits
écoliers
j'ai des invités protocolaires de haut niveau
supervisé et ça fait partie de moi
devenir la vie que j'ai un matin
est entré dans la maison à travers le fjord
suis et là jésus bon endroit madame
président tous les points où est le
Président
Je ne l'étais pas, bien sûr, mais je suis
belle histoire me fait plaisir
[La musique]
à la présidence du borussias à ce
objectivement le éprouvé c'est presque aujourd'hui
famille réagit
ligne de bus a considérable
protester contre la littérature jamais
il y a pour la wii et depuis le
pentagone qu'alors tous les murs à
les apparitions venaient d'apparaître dans l'aile nord
la salle plénière niveau les quatre grandes
mission
c'était impressionnant et elle
peut imaginer au premier instant
là non plus j'ai pas tout lu
seuls les très grands noms peuvent
parfois avec difficulté et
c'était impressionnant messieurs oui alors
même les petits les ont emmenés avec nous
tout était gravé dans la pierre
millimètre par mètre sous la loupe
pris et
Je suis ensuite allé à plus de 700 noms
[La musique]
pour moi c'est fondamentalement un
devenir le travail de ma vie, c'est ce que j'ai
Je ne pouvais pas imaginer au début
combien de travail ça fait alors c'est
pris dont je n'ai jamais entendu parler
il n'y a pas que l'oscar
région ouzbékistan tadjikistan et
loin loin loin dans le pays
Noms kazakhs avec des noms ukrainiens
le temps formé que j'aurais ça
mais ensuite ils ont dit oui tu peux
l'honneur mais un endroit qui
assez
puis le premier avait son nom
trouvé que c'était un absolu aha
l'expérience qu'il y a une telle personne devant moi
se tient parmi ces nombreux à l'époque
les soldats étaient
paris lisbonne encore trop petit et
modeste devant ce nom se tenait néanmoins
par mon dieu comment ça s'appelle
les lettres étaient difficiles à lire et
alors j'ai dans ma carte de visite
demandé et réfléchi à ma bonté
vous encore une telle question il n'y en aura pas
avoir
il avait une j'ai une carte de visite
a obtenu et a ensuite vu qu'il
professeur d'histoire à
Musée de l'Ermitage à Saint-Pétersbourg
étaient des femmes dans des camps de concentration
étaient avec moi et ça monte jusqu'au toit
passé devant les inscriptions là
m'a dit une fois que mon a aussi sur le
mur écrit et puis je me demandais
après le nom dit alors nous continuons
debout et puis soif il y a ça
nom mais où il est je le savais
ne pas
il était près de mon bureau dans le
Reichstag et puisque je les ai eu si souvent
vu oui et ludmilla à ostrava
Je pourrais alors entrer à nouveau
sonne le même jour et pourrait rejoindre
vous allez ensuite au nom je pense
c'est quelque chose de spécial pour quelqu'un
puis j'ai dit que j'étais si jeune
avait 16 ans quand je suis arrivé au camp il avait
19 quand la guerre était finie
nous avons eu de la chance d'avoir
marié et tu peux t'en remettre
pensez à ce concept bonheur qu'est-ce que c'est
chance
[La musique]
oui cette maison pour regarder ça
vous met également au défi de penser
la plupart des morts a le alors
enregistré en union soviétique
il y a eu aussi des morts dans ma famille
la soeur de ma mère voulait
épouser sa chérie avait à la
avant, il voulait en fait être médecin
mais il est tombé sur le chemin
et quand j'étais la mère de ça quand j'étais enfant
visite jeune homme est allé avec le mien
Grand-mère alors j'ai toujours vu une photo
avec un sol noir j'ai ça
pas compris alors
Aujourd'hui, bien sûr, je le vois différemment
ne doit plus jamais faire la guerre à personne
lieu de la terre à aucun
parce que nous, les mères, accueillons nos enfants
Ne les autorisez pas en quelques secondes
être tué j'ai des enfants aussi
je pense aussi que seuls les garçons et moi
Je veux que tu vives et que tu sois là
honorer ce que les soldats ont fait
Je dois mettre fin à cette guerre pour ça
les gens du vaste pays dont ils sont originaires
de nombreuses nationalités se compose plus le
fait un effort et j'aimerais lui offrir ce livre
donner un cadeau
[La musique]